for me it brought out a self-confidence
that I didn't really have before I came
to the program I wasn't used to
interacting with a whole bunch of people
that were like me you know different but
they were all kind of smart
one person that sticks out like a sore
Mohammed should end a was IRA he was an
amazing guy I mean still is amazing guy
but he graduated and he he was just so
charismatic he would just jump into
everything well Damien Damien was always
there is always always a guy in charge
but always always really interested in
getting you to the right places
when I came I didn't realize that she
could major in something like math which
which I'm doing now I plan to stay here
for a fifth year and get my master's
degree and then jump in the workforce
but i'm not sure where I'm thinking
maybe like since I have like a minor
computer science may be working for
google or apple
you'll get so much out of it socially
academically just everything personally
you'll feel yourself growing in
different directions you'll feel your
mind opening up to different different
things the diverse pneus of the program
is insane just come yeah